the one the only Nate Burleson GM FB you
literally do everything and I want to
talk about one of your jobs and one of
your co-workers okay
CBS before the games his pops of course
and now those soul sins yeah yeah that's
cool but some would say the cool it I'm
gonna say must be old enough Coulomb per
se that there is this perception of Phil
that is I think completely wrong that
he's a herb that he's square but I don't
know like what's your experience cuz I
think Phil's hilarious listener break
the mold Nate he's a full-fledged fool
yeah now let me let me give miss credit
he's a genius when it comes to football
breaking down film he has all these
thoughts in his head and even pregame
you can see them working out of thoughts
which is great because that just shows
ultimate preparation and we're all there
everybody's sitting there trying to work
through their thoughts so they can get
through everything they want to talk
about so quickly but in between the
commercial breaks yes some of the
funnest times ever and I could say this
yeah he's a little twisted up here man
like stuff he says right the stuff he
draws he can sketch some stuff that were
like it'll blow your mind in the moment
he'll like turn it to you so only you
can see it and I promise you if the
camera caught it we'd have to call HR
did not know that he doesn't do that
tell him just to show you this is one
piece of artistry that he dropped off ok
I'm sitting between I think the two most
employed people in NFL media radio shows
TV shows no but I mean what's it like
for both of you guys once you leave the
game you realize all right I gotta bust
my ass and work just as hard in my new
craft so like every opportunity is like
me being a rookie again and when I was a
rookie I walked in to the Minnesota
Vikings in I'm seeing
I'll take o pepper in anodized Minh fur
and I'm seeing Randy Moss swagged out
with a baggy suit and I'm like damn this
is the NFL these dudes pulling up and
Bentley's with spinners on it and I'm
like baby I'm a baby and I got a work
not only to make a name for myself but
to like get these guys attention and
that was my goal to get the greats
attention so like what we do now is if
we got to work one two three four jobs
we want to get attentions out of the
masses because we're still working I saw
Strahan a couple years
to go and I was like what's up me ain't
give me a piece of advice yeah he was I
never turned down the job
I said guys get comfortable start making
money yeah
and they start turning down
opportunities said when you were playing
and the coach told you need to do
something you're heading in the kid you
turn down an opportunity no we said we
don't change yeah cuz as soon as you get
complacent
it's another dude with a bigger name
maybe that's bigger ring a gold jacket
in the closet and he's gonna show up
whether he's good or not
and if he's great at his job you might
not we're not we're done yeah I do want
to jump off of something you said a few
minutes ago
where'd you brandy Moss yeah I was gonna
say you experienced the young Randy Moss
you experienced old random right the
first time I met Randy Moss I knew
immediately that if I got a atta boy pat
on the back from him I've arrived as a
wide receiver huh but I went about it
the wrong way
because I was trying to get his
attention like a thirsty dude at the end
of the night like I was like all right
as soon as I hit him with this
icebreaker we're gonna be best friends
forever man and I remember one day I was
I was getting ready for practice and I
think was Jermaine Dupri it
he had a music video and he's wearing
the Marshall 88 Jersey so I'm like in my
little dorm room at Jenny Kim's like
this is it man and I remember us doing
conditioning and I'm standing next to
him I'm literally like gasps and myself
up like a dude about to walk across the
bar and ask a girl for the numbers like
hey Randy
voice is cracking I'm a grown man I was
like did you see that remain Dupre video
yeah add your Jersey on there and he's
run next to me he looks at me he just
keeps all right I was crying
listen I wrote a girl a note do you like
me yes you know in the fifth grade and
she crumbled it up and threw it at my
face Oh Randy mom hurt me more like my
feelings were crushed and I was like
damn I blew it
and it was crazy is like once I started
making plays like that's when he came
and was like all right like I know you
love the game and I know you're one of
the good ones it's funny I think to hear
him say that because I don't think
people always realize that football
players can also be fan boys first time
Randy Moss came on the plane I missed
row 27 by the window and he said can I
sit here I was like yeah sure
yeah I mean that's the way I felt but
the like Nate's saying to the one thing
I learned from him in our hurry is his
perspective on the game was like amazing
he could almost see the game almost like
a quarterback you understood offense and
defense and you know he understood when
this play was stupid and he wasn't gonna
tell the coach that's a stupid play Sims
I see you know what it was yeah I mean
and I just I really enjoyed being around
Calvin is the forgotten guy yeah if I'm
creating a player in Madden he's six
five running a four three and his name
is Calvin Johnson yeah
but he's never mentioned in the Jerry
Rice tee Oh Randy Moss top three but I
would argue his physically as gifted as
any of them if not more no question I
mean it's the same individual that broke
Jerry Rice's single-season record yeah I
watched him do it
I watched games where he'll put up a
buck 90 and we go to the meeting and
after a loss Shaun Jefferson was a
former player why receiver he was our
wide receivers coach he say Calvin I
need you to do more no I'm thinking like
damn what you want to do go for 250 and
Calvin would say anything
he was quiet you know his mother a
doctor daddy worked on the real world so
he had this blend of blue-collar and
high IQ and that was his approach to
life and he was just not as hit say
alright coach next game go put up 300
that was that was steed right now he was
gifted
I seen him bench 225 twenty times and
racked it on 20 because he didn't want
to embarrass the rest of receivers right
I was I was spotting him on that [ __ ]
I'm ready got like nine things like 19
and he goes more like 20 and he gets up
baby was odd she's just crazy 20 and
then I pulled to sound like bro I seen
that what are you doing you could have
did more that oh you know but he was he
was that type of talent man and I when
he was playing maybe I was a prisoner of
the moment I said if I could choose one
I would choose Calvin and if he had
longevity by a side he would go down as
possibly the best receiver ever if he
played 15 years possibly the best yet a
very Terrell Davis career yeah very
quick nine years less powerful powerful
but it's not enough for us to stack them
up with the greats and you just look at
Randy's numbers you can't put Cal
that conversation now Randy was just
pure speed and capsulated if they put
shoulder pads and cleats on his same
boat and he was actually a good football
player that can catch and track the ball
like no other yeah it would be Randy
Moss and Randy Moss at the greatest late
hands ever even though coaches say don't
panic
remember your cues don't give anything
away like we panic like we don't
remember our cues and we give everything
away like the ball is in the air you
start hearing your own breath and you go
from and if you're a really good DB I
know it's a small detail but you could
hear a guy breathing hard and then you
see his eyes go from here to here yes
and that right there is a cue that
something's coming right Randy would
like a look and the ball would be coming
and his face doesn't move his hands
doesn't move his breath doesn't move and
then right when it gets to him he's like
velcro like that's something that's you
might not see ever and that's not
something you coach is something that
God said hey Randy I got a little extra
for you right you the man that was
awesome